bonsoir à tous alors pourquoi on m'a
demandé pourquoi moi pourquoi
aujourd'hui je pense comme ils l'ont
expliqué on m'a demandé de venir moi
parce que je suis étudiant entrepreneur
que j'aime n'est pas mal de projets que
j'ai ma propre entreprise entreprise
mais honnêtement ce soir je suis pas là
pour vous parler de ça ce soir je suis
là pour qu'on parle et qu'on parle avec
le coeur donc je vais même pas vous
présenter des slides ou des diapos parce
que voilà je veux juste qu'on parle d'un
truc qui me qui me tient à coeur c'est
les passions
quel est votre passion j'ai une amie
elle m'a dit un jour julien franchement
tu as de la chance tu te rends pas
compte parce que tu as vraiment une
passion et cette passion bat a réussi à
en faire ton métier ou ton métier et à
réussir en faire cette passion c'est que
ça marche dans les deux sens alors cette
phrase elle est assez intéressante
on peut la décomposer en deux morceaux
il ya tout d'abord le premier morceau
c'est tu as une passion
oui j'ai une passion c'est l'ingénierie
et la deuxième partie c'est cette
passion m'a lancé ça devient ton métier
alors on va s'intéresser premièrement à
la première partie de la phrase
le fait que j'ai une passion alors c'est
quoi une passion c'est difficile à
définir une passion quand même moi
personnellement quand j'entends le mot
passion je pense à un truc c'est quand
on est heureux le matin de se lever et
d'aller faire cette chose pour moi si
c'est ça c'est une passion donc ça pour
moi c'est la définition de la passion
malheureusement moi je vois je suis en
école d'ingé je suis aligné sa de
strasbourg en dernière année
quand je parle avec d'autres personnes
de ligne ça j'ai des copains aline ça je
leur demande ça te plaît là ce qu'on
fait ça t'intéresse
je trouve ça bien et puis je disais
ouais
aujourd'hui mais comment ça ça te plaît
ou ne plaît pas ouais ouais ça me plaît
mais bon pas pas plus que ça et quand on
les questionne un peu et qu'on est qu'on
parle avec eux plus longuement
on s'aperçoit qu'en fait ils sont là en
école d'ingénieur mais ils n'ont pas
vraiment la passion c'est à dire qu'ils
sont là pourquoi ils sont là parce qu'il
n'était pas trop mauvais en math pas
trop mauvais en physique au lycée pas
trop mauvais globalement à l'école et
que les profs leur ont dit bon écoute et
pas trop mauvais vin en prépa bon ils
sont allés en prépa et puis la prépa les
emmener à l'école d'angers
c'est comme s'il y avait un peu la
lumière ils sont rentrés par hasard et
je trouve ça dommage quand même c'est
quand même triste que des gens qui n'ont
pas cette passion se retrouve quand même
à devoir faire ça afin de vous refaire
des choses qui n'aiment pas forcément
et honnêtement enfin quand on va quand
on regarde aujourd'hui les jeunes qui
vont sur le portail le feu portail apb
admission post bac qui permet en fait
aux étudiants de sélectionner une voie à
la sortie du bac ils choisissent pas la
meilleure solution ils choisissent pas
ce qui leur plaît le plus il choisit
soit la voie générale soit ce qui leur
déplaît le moins c'est quand même triste
donc il ya vraiment un gros problème par
rapport à ça les gens n'ont pas de
passion les gens n'ont pas de passion
alors pourquoi pourquoi les gens n'ont
pas de passion moi je pense que les gens
n'ont pas de passion parce qu'ils ne
sont pas curieux ou du moins ils ne sont
pas assez curieux pour découvrir de
nouvelles choses
moi je vais prendre mon cas par exemple
pourquoi j'ai cette passion de
l'ingénierie je pense que j'ai cette
passion de l'ingénierie parce que quand
j'étais petit beaucoup de cheveux des
toiles se sont alignés pour que j'ai
cette passion on ma j'ai eu l'occasion
de étant petit d'aller dans de nombreux
ateliers de visiter un petit peu une
scierie d'autres ateliers etc etc
j'ai passé mes vacances à la ferme
j'avais j'avais des machines agricoles à
disposition honnêtement je pense que
tout ça a fait que j'ai eu cette passion
et puis aussi mes parents mes parents
qui m'ont je sais qu'ils me regardent
qui m'ont tous permis toutes les
expériences que j'ai voulu faire ils me
les ont autorisés rien été interdits de
ce point de vue là donc tout ça ça m'a
vraiment donné une passion la passion
l'ingénérie et c'est ça qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui
eh ben je me lève le matin et j'ai envie
de me bouger parce que j'ai vraiment
cette passion
la deuxième partie de la phrase que mon
ami m'a dit dans je viens tu as de la
chance tu as une passion et en plus tu
en fais ton métier c'est en fait ton
métier je connais beaucoup de gens qui
ont quand même cette passion ou une
passion en général je vais parler de
toutes les passions général parce
qu'après on va dire que je presse je
prêche pour ma paroisse qui est
l'ingénierie mais pas du tout je prenne
vraiment
toutes les paroisses de toutes les
passions si vous avez une passion et que
vous pouvez en faire un métier mais
honnêtement
foncez vous avez quel âge vous avez à
les 20 22 23 ans
qu'est ce que vous avez à perdre si vous
êtes motivés si c'est votre passion
mais allez-y bougez vous je vois bien
trop de gens qui qui qui se disent
motivés qui disent avoir une passion
j'ai des copains ils disent avoir des
passions il est motivé et pourtant au
quotidien ils ne font rien pour faire en
sorte que cette passion devienne leur
activité ou leur métier et pourtant il
en rêverait et je leur dis mais bougez
vous faites le alors il se trouve
toujours des excuses pour pas le faire
si souvent des excuses de temps j'ai pas
le temps j'ai pas le temps j'ai pas le
temps mais moi je fais la même école que
et pourtant j'ai le temps de faire plein
d'autres choses à côté
donc je leur dis c'est pas une excuse
qui recevable si vraiment j'avais
vraiment envie de faire les choses si tu
étais vraiment motivés tu le ferais et
j'espère en vous disant ça que vous
allez faire cette analyse sur vous même
et que peut-être vous allez arrêter de
dire et peut-être que vous allez faire
si vous avez vraiment la passion et que
vous pouvez faire votre métier
faites-le vraiment fait le arrêter de
trouver des excuses et faites-le alors
je suis d'accord ce sera pas sans
sacrifices
moi je pense pas avoir sacrifié grand
chose parce que comme c'est ma passion
c'est ce que j'aime
donc je pense pas avoir sacrifié grand
chose mais c'est vrai que si on prend
dans l'absolu j'ai un petit peu sacrifié
peut-être ma vie sociale ou d'autres
choses au profit de de tout ça mais
honnêtement au jour d'aujourd'hui je ne
regrette strictement rien je ne peux pas
le regretter parce que quand je me lève
le matin je fais ce que j'aime
donc c'est impossible de l'été d'être
passé à côté de quelque chose je pense
même pas au final est vraiment passé à
côté de quelque chose parce que parce
que vraiment je fais ce que j'aime
alors au niveau des solutions je je je
veux pas je n'arrive pas avec une
solution clé en main
bien sûr que non
mais j'arrive je pense j'ai quelques
pistes de solutions à apporter sur ce
problème alors on va prendre le premier
problème qu'ils prennent de la passion
comme j'ai dit il faut être curieux il
faut être curieux et les gens trouvent
des excuses au fait pas être curieux en
disant que bon c'est compliqué de voir
beaucoup de choses etc etc
certes mais aujourd'hui quand vous voyez
la puissance d'internet tout ce que vous
pouvez trouver sur internet toute
l'instruction vous pouvez trouver sur
internet toute la connaissance
disponible sur internet
les encyclopédies libre en ligne sont un
très bon exemple
eh ben au lieu d'aller sur internet pour
regarder des choses qui n'apporte pas
vraiment une grosse connaissance vous
pouvez aller sur internet est vraiment
voir des choses qui apporte une
connaissance et parmi toute cette
connaissance vous trouverez forcément
quelque chose qui vous passionne entre
guillemets qui vous intéressent du moins
et qui plus tard pour à vous passionner
et puis internet c'est une première
étape c'est peut-être la mort ce qui va
faire que vous allez vous intéresser à
quelque chose
un sujet en particulier et après sortez
allez parler à des gens qui ont les
mêmes centres d'intérêt que vous et si
vous allez les voir et que vous discutez
avec que vous allez voir vous avez des
points communs et vous allez ça va faire
comme une émulsion et vous aller de plus
en plus aimé ce centre d'intérêt et
pourquoi pas en faire votre passion ça
c'était le premier point le deuxième
point au niveau des solutions cbc cette
passion il faut en faire son faux pas en
faire son métier mais si on le peut et
qu'on en a envie mais c'est très bien
d'en faire son métier
alors là la solution basse et c'est de
foncer
de toute façon la route est pavée
d'échecs
il ya aucune route qui n'est pas pavée
d'échecs il ya que les gens qui n'ont
jamais tenté qui qui peuvent dire qu'on
n'y arrivera pas et comme il n'y a que
les gens qui ont tenté qui peuvent dire
que la route est pavée d'échecs
il faut bien comprendre que vous y
arriverez jamais en un seul coup mais
bon à l'âge que vous avez vous pouvez
essayer plusieurs fois c'est pas un
problème
et si vraiment vous êtes passionné
essayé plusieurs fois ben ça va pas vous
poser plus de problèmes que ça passe que
vous aurez vraiment la passion pour
essayer essayé essayé encore et encore
jusqu'à
2 ça marche franchement osé ne baissez
pas les bras et n'abandonnez jamais si
c'est vraiment ce que vous voulez faire
j'espère vous avoir donné quelques
pistes de réflexion et j'espère ce soir
en faisant se tait dans l'esprit de tedx
avoir partagé avec vous une idée une
espèce d'idéologie de 2 qu'est ce que
sait faire un métier qui nous plaît et
j'espère que si j'ai réussi à en faire
réfléchir certains d'entre vous et qui
vont faire leur petite analyse / / / la
situation qu'ils ont vis-à-vis de leur
passion et du travail et si jamais ça
permet de faire en sorte qu'ils se
bougent et qui se lance dans quelque
chose si on ne serait ce qu'un seul qui
fait sa grâce à ce que je dis ce soir
et bien honnêtement je pense que j'aurai
réussi mon talk merci à vous